how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have some really big news about
the Wan Division Series coming to Disney
Plus cast members have officially joined
the show for one division they have the
code names of Timmy and Adam Timmy and
Adam don't really mean anything like I
said their code names they're
placeholders for characters that they
have not revealed yet but having said
that we definitely know who Timmy and
Adam are there's really no hiding it
officially cast to eight-year-old boys
to play the roles of Timmy and Adam so
it's very obvious at this point that
these two boys are going to be the two
children of Wanda and Vision Wiccan and
speed it's widely speculated before
however there's a bit of a different
twist now Wiccan and speed are going to
be two very important characters moving
forward in the MCU and they're not going
to develop as you think they are two
reports it is said that Wiccan and speed
are going to grow up very rapidly over
the course of only a week in fact
they're going to go from eight-year-olds
to teenagers in the course of only a few
episodes this is widely believed to be
because each episode of the Wanda vision
series will do a time jump the first
episode being set in the 50s the second
being set in the 60s and so on and so
forth it makes sense based off of a
recent leak that we've heard a recent
leak tells us that it is actually Agatha
Harkness who creates a perfect world for
Wanda of this new world does not
technically exist in reality so that
would explain why the children could
grow up so quickly and how the show
could time jump but the fact that Wiccan
and speed are going to be introduced in
this series and the fact that they are
going to grow so fast means one of two
major things one is that they grow up
like perfectly normal children and
teenagers and eventually grow into their
full powers speed of course has
superhuman speed he's just like his
uncle Quicksilver and Wiccan has magical
ability so he is just like his mother
The Scarlet Witch both extremely
powerful characters that go on to lead
the young Avengers now it's heavily
speculated that the Young Avengers
aren't coming it's been set up quite
nicely in the MCU so far so this is one
theory and one possibility of what could
happen in the future of the MCU the next
theory I've actually covered on another
channel of mine and real quick as you
all know I have multiple different
channels and I want to thank dashlane
for
making my life so much easier - Lane is
a password manager and a digital wallet
and with me having so many different
channels it's hard to remember all of
these passwords sometimes and even when
I do remember them it's super annoying
to have to type them in all the time
or like when I do a giveaway for you
guys it's super annoying to have to
re-enter my credit card information each
time well I don't have to with dashlane
this app has helped me so much and the
best part about it is it's free it's
especially handy if you have multiple
different social media accounts like
twitch YouTube Twitter Instagram
Facebook this makes it to where you
don't have to retype your password in
each time on your phone or on your
computer and it's completely safe in
fact it doesn't even store your master
password so if they get hacked by any
chance you're not at risk if this sounds
like it can make your life easier and
you want to support the channel be sure
to click the link in the description
down below to download the app for free
on one device and also automatically get
a 30-day free trial of premium no credit
card required at signup but as for the
second theory which I think some people
could be expecting if you've read the
House of M series in the comics is that
one of them or both of them could die
now they don't necessarily have to die
they could just be taken away somehow I
thought the Harkness does truly create
this reality for Wanda when she destroys
the reality the kids may go with it and
just like in the House of M series this
could cause her to go insane it has been
speculated for a long time now that the
Scarlet Witch could end up becoming the
next big villain in the MCU we already
know that she's going to be appearing in
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness but there is no mention of
vision or her children is this because a
Gotha Harkness created the reality that
she was living in for the series but
then it was taken away and the villain
has not yet been revealed for Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness we
all think it's nightmare but could it
perhaps be the Scarlet Witch her
involvement in the movie has not yet
been revealed the only thing that we
know is the fact that she's going to be
in the movie but perhaps the reason that
she is in the movie is because she's the
villain she would certainly be one of
the strongest villains that the Avengers
would have gone up against if you think
about it the Russo brothers did say that
the Scarlet Witch in Avengers and
was going to defeat Thanos that is until
he fired on everybody so if she could
take on Thanos one on one and almost
defeat him
when Captain America Iron Man and Thor
couldn't defeat him three on one
then the Avengers are definitely going
to have their hands full if the Scarlet
Witch freaks out and becomes the new
villain so which way do you think that
they're going to go do you think that
they're going to have Wiccan and speed
be introduced into the MCU to be the new
young Avengers or do you think that
perhaps this will be a tragedy for the
Scarlet Witch and she will go on to be
the MCS next villain let me know in the
comments down below also don't forget to
give the video a like if you enjoyed it
and subscribe to my channel with the
notifications turned on so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 and I also have my Infinity
Gauntlet and G fuel giveaway going on as
well I'll put a link to that in the
description down below as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof